we're just so obsessed with race now
it's like always on my mind I was on the
phone my insurance agent last week he's
like what color is your car I was like
geez I thought you're Progressive
and look I'm a pretty Progressive guy
but I noticed sometimes we get so
Progressive these days we actually end
up kind of racist again like I used to
have my friend now I'm very aware he's
my black friend don't say any stupid
don't piss him off don't offend him
that's not progress I'm obsessed with
his skin color now I never thought about
it before everything I say I'm second
guessing I'm like hey buddy I never see
any more you always banging your
girlfriend you're like a sex slave ass
ah
oh no I'm just saying you know you're
whipped ah damn
no I mean you know I I just want to hang
he's like screw this I'm out of here I'm
like all right I'll see you later Jesus
Christ holy hell
That's not healthy